si par
miracle pas
républicaine
apostolique au moment où
[Musique]
le peuple français peuple souverain
celui du pays des droits de l'homme et
les citoyens jamais peut-être un texte
le futur c'est réussi celui dont tant
d'autres ont dit qu'ils avaient une
dimension universaliste me porté par la
présidence
je vous promets que les loi n'entraîne
obame
a dégagé
alors ensuite bien entendu le maire et
le conseil municipal s'organisent comme
ils l'entendent c'est même d'ailleurs
lors de voyages
s'ils veulent travailler
selon le principe de subsidiarité qui
nous est si cher que nous devons à sucre
ap depuis quelques siècles déjà même
avant plein temps bien ils le font comme
ils l'entendent
[Musique]